When I get angry, you're making a plane.
Look, now that Memo Farm is nearby,
since nothing will happen, the police in the morning of the accident
Yes, this is the army of
oats.
subscribe
subscribe  sign up
subscribe,
what should I do, we find out it's weird, it's
weird, in the conversation match, Yusuf is
in the past, forgive what happens,
motive shooter, hook, no stress, no eclipse today, the
program does not want the eclipse, the cook, the
message is good for you
.
What will we get for Mommy a cop
who did it all here give me some paint 93
[Music]
Yes guys finally the champion
There were few pictures of this today, just social
daddy Anyway, I listened to
new music after a day of selling fruit,
math, math practice in the evening, it's a
Renault 9 joke, isn't it
[Music]
[Music] no
matter what I say, it's
cute no matter what you say, I said it's dishonest
Friends tea Good date in bed  we knit i
don't want to try to
overtake what is stop what to extend akresta saying
problems Sago soda zombie Bye bye
group hearing follow Diamond [ __ ] robot
how cold The group is on your head or
this car That's why it's open
to onions Love boil you girl we don't look up and
down a Style is boiling
[Music  ] Is
it the right one?
It's a little closer Okan henden We
can do it today it's going to be very
nice I'll check it in order
it has done something it has done
message Girls tonight bro very good
result How late  We're going to miss the day, I
'm going to miss you privately, I'm going to send you a quick message to
our village in such an organismic
way anyway, he was hanging out
and he changed it immediately, I
'll give it to
you, I hope I'll tell
you, it was a bad thing, take
it, I said marriage, I think it's a very beautiful
phone, fortune teller  feature IOS truck
see what time the leak is going and fruit
1.30 Dinçer Sliding me the girls
American servants look at our mother and her special
parts on Isparta Junction Is this ship on the Isparta Junction
Is
this my camera Jingle micro television
always plays Water Tank phone I miss the
period showing compass winner The doctor
makes a fake feast A poor person does
not know  I can't say Erdi I kiss you with glue
Brother, brother,
I'm
hungry Have a good day, the program is patient, observe the
Minister, come from this page, how is it No
, I was typing Android, what will I do by mistake, what will I do
?
slingshot Istanbul 21 ozone or if it's on holiday, please
give me the tooth bear and I think it will come out, is
it open today
This event is
still on vacation. The name of the Minister of Health So
me or the cherry 19 price is ours or This is the
same Ok okay Religious strong on top of
it I saw the same relationship,
what did the capitalist say, I checked the car
today mom or yours in a little
while 11i
Oh bon appetit no kind  It's old that
[Music]
This is an excuse to look wholesaleadverb ostime
already gong the same mistake never again, let me say I extended
a black Bluetooth to a forbidden deserted station
We
're counted.  053
I am yours, then I express you in plenty of time
13 mistakes, time will
not be blessed with the same light, I guess,
no baby how is that pill
How much music represents the room, all
I said is because Canon goes, "Please
check
this Adana bone and when is the League match
, Emin Efendi song or something, we are
sick. Oh, my mother dear,
I loved it, the cup reception station is the
source.
12 imam hatip dialogue with tomato paste 75
this 13602  You are talking about Imam was in the Ottoman
Passat Okay then Okey
Never stayed again Better health
this event ha
this incident ha this incident
this incident
this incident this incident
this
event  College
Coat by others on that woman look
this event ha
this event
ha this
incident  Did you write the following comment
By the way, even
a longer phone may not
be enough
.  yisi ooo
subscribe
what's it going to take
a call
oo
subscribe
do you
or stay
subscribe subscribe
subscribe
that who
mmi
subscribe who subscribe
subscribe
that who
subscribe  subscribe
subscribe who subscribe
subscribe
who he
what do I do
subscribe
this movie
subscribe subscribe
subscribe
this status
subscribe subscribe
subscribe subscribe is
it a lot
subscribe
what do I do or
what do
i do subscribe it  l
subscribe
this microbe
subscribe subscribe
subscribe
o
No my love where are you
subscribe subscribe
Ben Buddha
subscribe
No my love
this İbo ft
subscribe
what this book came out
I am my uncle Osman
subscribe
oooo
what he wrote
subscribe
then
subscribe subscribe
this team
subscribe
subscribe subscribe
or don't do
it or this month I tried it all
subscribe subscribe
subscribe
I never
subscribed
you know and
subscribe
this both ordered
subscribe subscribe subscribe
subscribe
what will happen
what will happen or
subscribe
subscribe  he is  l
what will be
subscribe
my love
what will I do
what do i do
subscribe
subscribe subscribe
subscribe  subscribe
subscribe
subscribe subscribe subscribe subscribe subscribe subscribe
the line, which has made a great contribution to zty health and safety, is being carried out with the United
States of America
as long as they do not work with the same sensitivity from now on
. Another meeting with the
Prime Minister of the United Kingdom, Israel
In our meeting, we are often the
prime
minister of Greece. Yes, if you want, we revived it from our
meeting, we
decided to continue the dialogue mechanisms
, taking steps to support the prime ministership between our countries.
Aunt yesterday, I
also met with the Prime Minister of Hungary, Mr
Ormanlı, that Turkey's contribution to the defense of fish, which also exchanged views on Turkey-European Union relations before the Summit in  I greet you with respect,
my dear friend, NATO Secretary General, for their successful hosting in the Zorlu epidemic Feet
o
No no 60161 Yo drinking Yes a Mesut
Özdemir Hello rally dumm shell
[Music]
Count your thoughts on Afghanistan very clearly
He expressed his flag o
What about me?  give you Two me and Aydın from
Afghanistan and this Board especially want
to give support there first
Bursa automatic cake pudding
besides American
technology Derici support is of great importance now on certain issues
Aziz interview Also, of course,
it is possible to put aside the reality of the Taliban here,
as well as many meetings with them
You can continue with the steps we will take,
you sweet, the other issue is in Afghanistan,
we think 40 in Pakistan, we think
that our branch of taking us back is
Tellerin, we say that it is the best, and we want it together with them
.  As of now, we are in agreement,
it is not the issue of sister Ertuğrul's
expiration s400. Of course
, it is
not possible for es400 not to be on the agenda in such a meeting to be held here
, but Özgür You also expressed the
same thought to the President, whatever your opinion was before
, and besides, the
issue of ep35.  Again, I expressed to them in the same way
that
3/4 of the year,
what are the steps we can take regarding the defense industry?
Let's open up bro and we're living for a long time. London Sir, I
want to ask a question about my President, my President. He held a press conference today
and Zehra said that
she made a statement about the speeches she made about Istanbul before. She said that her
words for today were perhaps misunderstood.
a He mentioned
that the two countries
have a payment to work together on Syria and
Libya The reason for your relations with Pizza
is France.
In
this process, when you told me that it is not possible for me to be against, it is a
pity that some
gatherings made up such things, but
it is not possible to be against my love,
and
I am telling you this as a friend, since this video
is like this
, you will also recommend them in the next process.
If it happens
, I am not saying it as a
citizen if
it was a very patient age.  Denizli asik Sefai should think about this subject in
Turkish, Syria in the background
spoke a certain way,
can we do a job for the customer? Can we do the mother's work?
We focused on the school. We focused on the school.
Your big heart wants it, but
İbrahim Tatlıses Uncle İbrahim's home
credo mutwa nstep form electric Primer
if you want your holiday homework plane
dreams It's over too sie so
many
Of course, I agree with these statements about the body, that
is, I share the thought that it will be a quiet century
and a nice meeting between us,
whether it is in the Aegean or in other regions
.
when he understood  Are we special from the right?
I can easily call you by special
names. Thus
, we take our steps as bra Istan without any problems, and we can
understand the troublesome issues again,
let's put them on the table, friends we know who can see
, work on them, it's nice,
let them bring the final decision by rapping and
deciding this world  Then think about our
steps, some examples
, about what will happen to a crime,
and when we give the salt, the notification will be given to you in the
same year. We remove the problem from you in the same way.
[Applause]
Sir, can you clarify the agreement you will say about him tonight,
that is, was
there an agreement
with the American side and the Taliban on Turkey's holiday airport
operation?  At 12
Forum
, we conveyed to Deniz Aydın that it was over
, as soon as we met. America's current stance is clear, then Sea
defense may be steps to be discussed,
we are talking about particles,
what exactly do you mean?
a
repair, a repair period has been entered,
you can eat, thank you, I will be back in merse
Of course right now We have a face-to-face meeting
se32 With this summit, we really
understood what you had with you charging Of course
, my work called my meeting, my meeting seven and your
happiness This process between permanent turkey-america
sports Silence
About halfway through our own meeting
Hourly Aşkın had a bilateral meeting
or after that, it leads to our meeting between the delegations,
and with these meetings, of
course, Company glass of milk.
Let's listen to our thoughts on dormitories. At the
time, the boss is like Syria.
Of course, then we are entering a new process that will happen if I do not receive it,
and we can defend these issues in
our compositions
.
This agreement is worth 100 billion dollars. Currently,
we need to open them to this goal, around 22 23 billion dollars, and we
have received an agreement with
Cecely on this subject.
What would your evaluation be in
terms of the continuation of the relations, I say that it is positive in terms of the continuation of the relations,
that is,
I
invited him to Turkey, not too much at
the moment.  kilde Also, if he used to say his country, he used to say that he used to
pray for cheese and meringue internet child,
if there is a new tasyakan interview
,
you said that I hope there will be a meeting that will make you forget April 24 in 1915.
I have given the President Fatih Special. I have two questions. We will have two questions. We have just
said that we did not.
They were
giving advice not to go to Turkey.
I wonder if he would change this, would anyone make it a little
easier? Thank you. Just now
, of course, all the events are funny, the
message is sports, I'm on top of it.
For example,
Germany abroad is my wish for you. Yilmaz
Russia has sent
a delegation. We will show
what kind of Carrots will be bought after the meetings of the delegation sent by Russia to Turkey,
but I am
hopeful,
because of the cawwot trouble, few countries can't open the door right now,
this later this
Because women don't stay closed all the time like that, we also
write them.
There is a problem with the discount at the
moment, but
during the meeting we will meet, Inshallah,
I am hopeful, I
hope it will open its doors from there.
I hope
it's opening too  We will not do it, we will do it.
It is against the United
Nations.
subscribe subscribe
subscribe